ah
por temor a importar posibles nuevas
variantes del cob y 19 de otros países
europeos el gobierno británico está
pidiendo a la población en estas
vacaciones de verano no viajar al
exterior o solo hacerlo a países
permitidos entre los que hasta el
momento no está ni francia ni italia ni
españa ni grecia que son los destinos
favoritos de los británicos buscando sol
para estas vacaciones de verano se está
promoviendo lo que se conoce como
staycation que es quedarse en el país
visitar otras regiones de inglaterra o
del reino unido para impulsar además
esta industria que está bastante
afectada durante la pandemia sin embargo
como viajar ya es permitido es legal se
espera que cientos de británicos visite
los países del mediterráneo pero a un
precio mucho más alto porque además de
permanecer en cuarentena a su regreso
tienen que presentar pruebas negativas
de kobe 19
[Música]
la unión europea ha aprobado la creación
del certificado digital un documento en
el que se podrá saber si una persona
antes de viajar ha sido vacunada de la
cob y 19 tiene anticuerpos por haber
superado la enfermedad y tiene un test
negativo el objetivo es volver a
facilitar la movilidad dentro de la
unión europea a punto para la temporada
de verano y entrará en vigor el próximo
1 de julio todas las personas vacunadas
con fármacos aceptados por la agencia
europea del medicamento tendrán el
acceso a este certificado aunque los
países son libres también de aceptar
otras vacunas como la china sino farm o
la russa sputnik además la unión europea
también ha decidido abrir las fronteras
a todas las personas amparadas de fuera
de la unión europea o que provengan de
países con una situación epidemiológica
positiva algo que afectaría sobre todo
los viajeros provenientes de eeuu o de
reino unido
[Música]
italia se prepara a voltear la página de
las restricciones a partir del primero
de junio los restaurantes podrán servir
a los clientes en espacios internos
vuelven a abrir los estadios y las
instalaciones deportivas deberán
respetar un límite máximo del 25% de los
puestos ocupados y en todo caso no
podrán superar los 1000 espectadores al
aire libre y 500 en interiores los
viajeros de la unión europea que
presenten un certificado de vacunación o
un tester negativo de coronavirus
realizado 48 horas antes de la entrada
italiano deben someterse a confinamiento
y pueden viajar libremente entre las
diferentes regiones italianas se cambia
el horario del toque de queda pasa de
las 10 de la noche a la medianoche a
partir del 7 de junio medidas adoptadas
para incentivar el turismo con la
llegada del verano y para salvar este
sector que es crucial para la economía
italiana
[Música]